I'm the serial killer Levi bellfield
reportedly confessing to another murder
in an interview from prison let's go
straight to our crime correspondent
Martin brunt Martin just tell us how the
facts around this latest murder came to
light
well it began last year
um The Disappearance of Elizabeth Chow
has been an unsolved case for the
Metropolitan Police for 24 years but
last year Levi bellfield apparently told
a prison visitor at his prison in Durham
that he had killed Elizabeth Chow he
then later wrote a statement and all of
this was passed to the Metropolitan
Police but it was only this week on
Tuesday that two detectives went to
visit him in Franklin prison and he
confessed to the murder he described how
he had killed Elizabeth and most
importantly he gave the two detectives
some details of the location where he
left buried her body apparently at some
Woodland in West London she was last
seen in 1999 in the healing area of West
London now all of this is confirmed by
by bellfield solicitor Teresa Clark who
was in on the interview at Franklin
prison the detective spent up to six
hours interviewing bellfield
um Miss Clark says that he feels it's
important the family has closure and
Justice after so long of course he gains
nothing from this and there is never any
good publicity for Levi bellfield and
Belfield of course is one of Britain's
most notorious serial killers he's
serving a whole life sentence for three
murders including the murder in 2002 of
the school girl Millie Dowler
apparently Elizabeth Charles family have
shown some concern that it's taken a
year for the Metropolitan Police to go
and talk to face to face to bellfield um
the reason for that might be that
bellfield is notorious for playing games
with detectives to admitting a number of
other murders but it does appear that
the Metropolitan Police are taking him
seriously in this case and are preparing
to go and dig at that spot in West
London where he says he left the
student's body